get the subcommittee started
on SB 53 permitting the use of certain
refrigerants that are in compliance with
a Clean Air Act as we get started I just
kind of like to throw out I think
there's a few things that we're looking
for insight on and we've got gentlemen
here to speak to it this morning one is
whether or not there's any concern with
the overall policy two
um
I am I'll be looking for some guidance
on line six which has provided that any
equipment containing such refrigerant
shall be listed and installed in
accordance with safety standards and use
conditions imposed pursuant to such
designation where those safety standards
coming from who's implementing them
seems a little bit big to me personally
but I would like to start the
subcommittee meeting by welcoming Sean
Timmy to just give some information on
where the fire marshal is kind of
sitting on on this issue
um
sorry to surprise you that's okay good
morning State Fire Marshal
um thanks for having me here this
morning uh so I I was just for some
background we were asked for some fiscal
note
um just for asked about a fiscal note
when this came through initially uh we
looked at it and uh initiated that sir
said there was no fiscal impact that we
saw and then also that in our review we
didn't have any major concerns with the
bill as was written at that time uh
and then I know last week I was at the
National Fire Academy at a State Fire
Marshal Symposium that they held and I
know that you guys heard the bill and
there's some questions came up from our
about I guess our we had concerns about
it from the state fire code perspective
I think the the only
um I would say journaling probably not
major concerns at all
um the
the the probably the only gist of uh
that on the fire code side is the the
use of refrigerants uh the newer
refrigerants aren't
totally addressed in the current code in
our eight 2018 codes today right and I
think you heard some testimony the other
day I listened to the the hearing that
the the codes aren't going to catch up
for a while right so
on the fire code side one thing that I I
thought we could do is in the NFPA 55
which talks about some of the
refrigerant language the 23 edition of
NFPA 55 uh has the language on the fire
code side to address it so we could we
could pull that in uh if we wanted to on
the um
through the board of fog Control process
and then bring it forward through
ratification uh to the journal Court
um the way the board of Fire Control
works is that we can actually enact it
as soon as it's gone through the board
Fire Control and just needs a
ratification within a year so if there
was an eminent concern we could probably
get it addressed in by June uh speaking
with NFPA the engineers down at NFPA
though the really the the there's no
major concern from what we could tell
for refrigerants in quantities less than
ten thousand pounds in
um non-protected structure so typically
a non-sprinkled building you start
putting a Sprinkle system in and other
Protections in buildings you're talking
20 upwards of 40 000 pounds of the of or
the refrigerant products which is huge
numbers
um so the the advice that I was given
through National Fire Protection
Association Association FBA is that
there's really no you shouldn't really
have a major concern and then they would
quickly remind which I you know very
familiar with that there's alternative
means in in the code that
if someone were to present a new type
facility or a use that had in quantities
and those large quantities we can look
at it and and go ahead to the newer
codes and the new guidance that's out
there and use that as you know work with
the developers to to achieve any
additional protection that's needed so
um you know that their refrigerant so
they're still flammable
um you know there's still there's
ammonias and propanes and different
things that are used for flammables
excuse me for refrigerants out there but
the newer as as I understand all the
research I've been able to do in the
last week or so especially is that the
newer refrigerants are a little bit less
flammable than what um you know that
what we're seeing uh out there now
um so I mean I in my head that I I think
it's difficult to stand in the way of
the Clean Air stuff I think we have a
couple different means and opportunities
to get to where we need to if we're in
those large large quantities
um the way that I understand that the
bill is written
uh you know we're in some conversation
came out like our our home refrigerators
or our conditioner units units those are
very small quantities of a refrigerant
and they have to meet listing standards
whether it's UL or FM or the other
there's a number of nationally
recognized testing Labs out there that
list all of our many of our appliances
whether it's computers or you know the
refrigerators or microwaves or different
things like that or surge protectors for
instance right so they need to meet
those standards as I understand it
um and I think there's a gentleman here
that knows the refrigerant side very
that I I immerse myself from a
refrigerant in the last week it's
probably something I've not done in my
to over 20-year career in fire
protection engineering work but
um you know I think the bottom line is
that
um I feel pretty comfortable uh moving
forward with it
um you know recognizing there's a
federal need to move forward and help
cleaner air and things like that and I
think we have means to address it I I
think my ask is that um
if we Sunset the bill or when we catch
up and the stuff's in the code properly
right so uh I think I can get stuff in
the fire code probably by the end of the
year I think on the building code side
it's probably going to take a little bit
longer but we also have a means on the
building code side too and I'll let Phil
Sherman as the chair of the building
code review board speak but
um there's a means there that they can
get amendments in so we could take those
24 language and Pull It in sooner into
the 2018 codes and get it ratified so
I've been babbling a bit I think but I
think uh you know I I feel pretty
comfortable with where we're at I just I
guess I I reiterate my ask would be as
if we if we land on something like this
now as we just Sunset it so that it
allows time for the January 1st deadline
for the federal standards on the Clean
Air side for us to get caught up a
little bit in our codes I think that's
really the Crux of the problems I've
talked to some of my counterparts across
the country is that we you haven't had
time to catch up really catch up on the
codes code officials tend to be very
black and white and if it's not
explicitly written in the code that
sometimes we're reluctant to look at the
newer Technologies so
okay happy dance try to answer some
questions any questions from the
subcommittee
yeah representative true thank you Mr
chair when you say uh uh your uh uh
looking for it to be sunset you mean the
effective date is that what you
did I know I would think that we could
put some language in and I I haven't I
don't have it off the top of my head but
once we say once we have the 20 say the
24 edition of the code in place as our
State Building Code this this section
would be go away or would be repealed
essentially I don't know if that's the
proper way to do it or if we would catch
it later but I think I
one of the things in practice that's
difficult is we we've worked very hard
over the last few years to have a State
Building Code and a state fire code and
have a good process that
um the building code review board the
board of fire controls do all their
research and their homework and bring a
package to uh the house and the Senate
and say this is what we feel is good uh
for the state with the appropriate New
Hampshire amendments and we ratify it
and then so we have the the model codes
which are the published nationally we
make some New Hampshire changes we
codify that in a rule
um you you ratify it and you know anyone
working within the state or out of the
state can come and say oh this is an
Hampshire building code this is an
answer fire code these are the New
Hampshire amendments
uh We've also gone to the next step in
some legislation recently that we are
working very hard to put all the local
amendments together too so anyone comes
in can say State Building Code State
amendments oh I want to work in Concord
here's the Concord amendments and it's
very clean so I think when we start we
hear the confusions when we bury some
stuff in legislation and bury some stuff
in the code amendment process the design
World finds it a little bit clunky a
little bit harder to follow so they ask
that we've been trying to do is if if we
can when we can is any code Amendment
related stuff stays in the code
amendment process does that make sense
long answer
anything else
thank you very much I appreciate you
coming today absolutely
all right um Philip Sherman building
code review board
uh just here and then representative
Gerhart
12 I think you're here just for fun
hmm
thank you Mr chair uh I've taken the
liberty of just sort of putting my
thoughts down uh this may or may not
turn into something formal I I find in
my own mind that this is a little bit of
a solution looking for a problem in that
in conversations with your
representative Simon it's not that
anybody is trying to prohibit these it's
sort of just in case
so one we have a sort of a board bias
that we would prefer to keep
administrative type rules on the code
side not written into law we have four
or five sections of 155 a currently that
deal with specific issues and 50 percent
of them are stale out of date and
probably just need to be repealed in
other words the codes the model codes
have caught up they've dealt with them
no no big problem
what I would like to to propose is that
we have a way to tag on the 2024 cycle
of amendments it's 20 pages long because
they have to get into a bunch of
different sections and different codes
into our 2018 code amendment process we
have a hearing tomorrow with with Edna
sanity DNA on is it hb564 yeah 541 564.
564 to Simply ratify I think there's
eight amendments there that are working
their way through the process
we can bring the 2024 amendments to our
Board second week of April next week at
our monthly meeting I have a public
hearing second week of May at our normal
monthly hearing and then tag this on if
we can get the
Edna and related folks to to be able to
deal with that then in June
everything going according to plan
effectively they'd come into effect
around July first you know with
Governor's signature so that's my
preferred route
if you really really really need to have
a bill I've taken the liberty of trying
to mark up what's here now and it may it
may look like clarification although as
fire marshal to me indicates these
things have a bad habit of turning into
black and white so simply indicating
that we use the term municipal building
code amendments that's just editorial
but then to clarify that these need to
meet the New Hampshire State Fire and
Building Codes
referencing safety standards and I'm not
an expert on the Federal Regulations but
when I looked at it it looked like there
was a bit of a round robin where they
were they say meet the local building
codes but if the local building codes
don't have Provisions this bill would
allow someone to essentially come in and
not meet any standards so there there is
a lack there until we get these
amendments written into into our code
which can happen I think
relatively quickly
so that that's my two options preferred
let us just do the amendment thing give
us some assistance you know getting
behind it and then uh I don't know if
the proper word was sunset I use the
word kill but you can put the right
legal term on that uh but if if we need
to keep this bill going uh amend it so
that it clearly requires compliance with
the state codes and doesn't leave any
gray areas there
so that's what I had to say about that
any questions from the subcommittee
yes representative
I can
um
so are you saying that
you don't see a need for this this bill
not only don't I see a need for it
historically when we write code language
into state law things get stale
at one day there was a big discussion
about why we had to have this code
specific code on log structures
every model code in the country
references that code now it's just stale
there's no need for that legislation
what happens when a code goes into
legislation is everybody's hands are
tied there's no appeals there's no
ability to work with existing conditions
there's no ability to to deal with
special conditions that the code didn't
didn't address and local officials all
they can do is just say That's the Law
go do it so if I can just interject
because it was kind of my idea
representative true
they'd really like to get the stuff into
code and we think we may have a way of
doing it with 564. I talked with
um
senator
um Pearl this morning who's the head of
Senate Edna they have 564 coming before
them tomorrow and if we could amend 564
to add the code that's necessary to take
care of this we could have that done
hopefully by June which would meet our
deadlines
um I had just come up with the idea of
potentially passing this with a sunset
clause in it as kind of a stop gap
between now and when they got that into
code but that when they did get it into
code this would just Sunset and go away
so that wasn't in statute but it was in
the building code if that makes sense
go ahead and thank you thank you Mr
chair
um I believe the state biomass was
saying I think you're saying the same
thing
you don't like
things to be in code in and out of
essays
because it limits
correct
thank you yeah respectfully
okay so uh the thing is uh I'm very much
in favor of the idea of having the
people who are most knowledgeable and
also to some degree most flexible which
would be the building code review board
and so forth the people who are most
knowledgeable and most involved to have
them be the people where the rubber
meets the road I don't like locking
things up in statute if you don't have
to because as a building co-chair
Sherman has just said
it locks you in in a situation where uh
you can't easily change it you're stuck
with it so the the question I have is
whether this has been discussed with the
chairman Maguire because she is
extremely knowledgeable uh from her
professional background but also from
having been the chair or a ranking
member on this committee for years
um and and and because she has that
level of expertise and familiarity with
all of this uh I'd like to know that
that she's been consulted conferred with
and that she's on board
um so the the conversation that I have
had with her I haven't talked to her at
length about this particular proposal of
564.
um but she was just concerned that there
were concerns by the building code
review board or the fire marshal with
the actual refrigerants themselves which
there don't seem to be and I think she's
probably okay with that at this point
but as far as the overall scheme we'll
still run that past her
um before we move forward to see if she
has any input into it for sure good well
I mean the thing is what the fire
marshal was saying earlier in his
testimony was that that the concern that
I voiced and I wasn't the only one with
regard to the flammability issue uh but
to the degree that uh that the uh the
flammability is apparently is not really
a problem with this uh it's uh the
current the hfcs are somewhat flammable
I I didn't know that but then I have no
technical background in all of this uh
but uh that the family of the issue is
not an issue it's not a concern in terms
of going backwards uh and Fire Marshal
is saying that that we want to get in
line with uh the incoming Federal
requirements and so forth which are move
in the right direction for environmental
concerns and so forth uh so I think that
my concern has gone away on that and to
the guru we have a better process which
I think is what chairman Sherman is
talking about a better process overall
than as long as as Carol McGuire's on
board I'm on board
um yes go ahead representative Schmidt
if I could just clarify it's not that
these are not flammable that they're
less flammable uh the codes still have
restrictions especially as the fire
marshal said at larger quantities and
there are some very large refrigeration
systems out there universities hospitals
industrial sites and so forth uh so
there are requirements that need to come
into play here and the the Gap with this
bill is it's this round robin where the
feds represent the state but when you go
to the state there's nothing there yet
but the bill would say go ahead and use
this stuff so that's that's the Gap that
we're trying to close
okay thank you now our ultimate deadline
for this was July of 24 is that correct
all right so we do have until July of
24. are we going to have to overly Rush
the process to get it into code to get
it into 564 or will it have the a
reasonable vetting process as far as the
building vote code review board is
concerned and our esteemed chair is she
going to be comfortable with that
speed of process
by July of 2024 everything going
according to plan we should be on the
2021 codes and we can easily wrap these
amendments into that process which were
in the cycle of now uh what I'm
proposing is that we can get that into
the hopper for the 2018 code which is
already in effect in New Hampshire and
we've got some additional amendments
working its way through the system with
the hearing tomorrow right that was my
question though as opposed to trying to
get it connected to 564 and getting it
into the 2018 code is that going to be
overly rushed because we have until 2024
if we were to pass something like this
as a stop gap between now and when you
finish the process is it easier to give
you the extra time to get the job done
it's certainly easier but I don't know
is overly rushed everything gets overly
rushed as the things come to a head sure
at the end of the session right so okay
great
uh yes representative goalie thank you
Mr chair I guess my question goes to
do we need to
do anything regarding this in 564 or use
what the vehicle we have in front of us
that has already come forward with the
changes made
uh what was that again sorry
do we need to
really worry about trying to get this
into 564 versus using the vehicle we
have here in front of us and taking care
of the issue right here
instead of yeah I mean that would be the
other issue would just be to hang on to
this bill and attach the link well
yeah because either way you're going to
end up in a committee conference with it
because it's going to be a separate
um
well if this is a separate Standalone
the Senate agrees it won't be a
committee conference I'm sure it's
agreed to so if it's everything I'm just
suggesting it might be easier this is a
separate issue then putting it in
thoughts on that Mr Sherman
one one of the problems one of the
problems one of the tasks that's in
front of us is that because we're on the
Mechanical Code and building code
the amendments are written by the model
code folks against the 2021 code so if
we're going to put this in as an
amendment to the 2018 code we need to
add in the changes that occurred at the
model code level between 18 and 21 to
then modify them essentially again with
the proposed package so the package is
not written in a form that we can simply
pick it up and reference it right now
furthermore the model codes there are
two fire codes New Hampshire is on the
nfba code there's also an international
code council code there are amendments
to the international fire code which
does not apply in New Hampshire and we
need to work with the Fireside to be
sure that there isn't something there
that needs to be patched up on the fire
side because both both cycles of code
deal with flammable refrigerants they
both have provisions
um so I guess my concern is tagging to
564 because we know that that's we've
it's already been through the Full House
it's passed it's it's nice and clean
it's been thought out worked on for a
while and for building fire code stuff
I wouldn't be a bit surprised if it's
exact tomorrow because it's it should be
no issue at all and I guess my concern
is where there's so many questions about
this if we tag it into a very clean bill
that will likely pass I would be very
concerned about losing all of our hard
work on ratification of all those other
building code amendments and fire code
amendments because those we've already
established are good for New Hampshire
we need them like if they've already
been vetted through and I think if I
understand the schedule right you guys
will know better than I am but if we're
I think the building code review board
meeting is June 9th which is after some
of the deadlines if I'm not mistaken
yeah I had to go back and check the
deadlines if it was in May I think we
had plenty of time but if we're
stretched out to June that might be a
little late I'd uh I'd love to try to
stick with amending this work within
this bill if we can rather than I don't
say yeah I think that's representative
goalie's point and I don't unless
there's a problem with the building code
review board I'm not sure that I have a
problem with that I just had another
idea forgive me one way to do this would
be an amend it the way I indicate or
something similar to clearly reference
the state codes but then make it
effective July 1st of 2024 because that
would give us time to put it into the
2021 Hopper out it comes and at that
point we'd have state
code requirements again I don't disagree
with the with the potential upset the
apple cart with 564. it's simply that
right now there's no requirements the
code prohibits it
this would permit it but it wouldn't
apply any safety standards to it
Jeff
my question I guess goes back to
listening to the fire marshal earlier
couldn't this be taken care of in the
codes as an amendment before 2024.
I can get it at the June Board of Fire
Control and bring in an NFPA 55 and I
the research that I did nfba 855 I'm
sorry wrong one NFP 55
um the language in there it matches the
language in the ICC language uh and I
booked maybe one of these guys a little
bit there they've been in the weeds of
this far longer than I have but I think
um that path I mean the board of Fire
Control we get a that specific section
put into place in their June meeting and
then it would be in effect and then you
you guys we would ask for ratification
within the ratification bill for next
session
um and that would be that would cover it
we'd be well before the January 1st
deadline that the Clean Air Act stuff
needs to meet and it would be in the
fire code there would be a gap on the
building code side that but typically in
the statute the the you know won the
stricter one typically applies so I
think we have some protections the other
asked if I don't know if the gentleman
behind me can answer it but the you know
the what I was told by a couple of
Engineers that on the nfpsi and the ICC
side is that there's when they surveyed
the country that the the number of
people that would have these quantities
would we wouldn't be even tripping
against some of these thresholds that
are there I mean we have to put them in
place just in case the large
manufacturing facility or you know large
facilities go into play but you know I
think that
um I don't know I think it's almost to
me it's a little bit of the fear of the
unknown right that
um we're kind of a lot of the what ifs
but
um I guess I'm putting a little bit of
trust in I think the process that you
know the the a couple of experts that I
talked to have said that we have good
paths to go there I agree with that
through the alternative design process
if something came in tomorrow I I feel
pretty comfortable that we could address
it
um
you know and I I don't know that's I'm
starting to babble a little bit sorry
yeah so I think the other thing that
hasn't come into the conversation yet
that is part of the conversation is
industry and industries concerns that
there's just something in place that
ensures them that they can move forward
and continue to produce while we're
working out all the details
um
and I'm just reminded by the nodding
heads in the background that that's um
one of the concerns so
I'm I guess personally I'm still maybe
inclined to say if we put something into
statute with a sunset clause for now so
that there's something in place give you
guys the next year to work out all the
building code stuff bring it back to us
in legislation next year for
consideration you know as far as
adjusting it to meet these standards we
can get the codes in place before you
know June of next year 2024 and then
this would just Sunset and disappear and
then we would just have the codes the
way that we want it
um
I still think maybe the the best route
to go for now because we're these things
aren't going to start pumping into the
state before then anyway correct are
they
necessarily
you can't sell
right but there's no need for it and
before then correct well actually if
sorry guys if we could switch real quick
I'm gonna bring him up all three of us
need to be
well we could throw them on uh on a mic
on the side as well if we needed to
okay good morning everybody I'm Mike
nerosi I'm the director of government
Affairs 4-H or I the uh we represent all
the manufacturers of HVAC refrigeration
and water heating equipment in North
America we produce about 90 percent of
all the equipment that both commercially
and residential here in the US
um
the biggest thing is it for us right now
is certainty so we're as the chairman
mentioned July 1 2024 is when the EPA is
going to begin phasing down the use of
hydrofluorocarbons
um immediately by restricting the
existing Supply by 40 percent
the reason why we can't wait till July
2024 is because our manufacturers have
you know supply chain you know they need
to get things figured out ahead of time
they can't just in one month all of a
sudden divert equipment that's now
suddenly approved in New Hampshire
you know there could be scarcity
problems and it may take a while to
reallocate resources around
um we really just would you know this
legislation as I think others had
mentioned representative goalie you know
it's it's very straightforward we are
fine with a a sunset if that's you know
we don't oppose that at all if it's tied
to when the new 2024 codes are adopted
um but at the end of the day you know
being asked to we've been working on
this across the entire country right so
in many states we've been asked to just
trust the process with the code process
right I'll give you an example in
Georgia we've submitted four different
proposals to adopt these codes in
Georgia and all four were rejected
and and a lot of it comes from that well
we're on 2018 and that's 2024 we're
getting way too ahead of ourselves it's
like well wait this is a special
situation where the federal government
is mandating that we move to these new
refrigerants and we don't have time to
and and to sit and go through the
building code process extremely as the
gentleman said I mean everything go if
everything goes according to plan I mean
I've seen the plan go out the window
I've been working on this for six months
now the plan almost always goes out the
window because then somebody else is
introduced into the process they say
well wait a second I got a question on
this I got it and it just gets even more
messy so I'm a quick quick question
though for clarification and I think
this is the main thing that we're trying
to sort out if we were to pass a piece
of legislation like the legislations
that's that's sitting before us we could
start selling that refrigerant unless
it's effective in the future immediately
without the code in place correct yes
right so I think that that's the main
concern that everybody's trying to
balance is
getting something in place so that you
have the assurance that you need that
you are going to be able to sell and
that you know but what's the what's the
best timetable that we can take to make
sure that all of the boxes are checked
so that when we start selling we also
have the code in place to facilitate
that yes yes I understand that okay so
that that makes sense though so
um yes representative gerhardt thank you
chair
I'm just curious as to
well I'm a little concerned about us
tying ourselves this strongly to the
federal government so we have to now
follow everything that they say is fine
we say is fine we don't have any kind of
say so well I think it's on the road I
think it's more so that the federal
government is just restricting the
production of certain refrigerants that
we use so we're not going to be able to
get them because people aren't going to
be able to make them so this but it's
also okay yeah so this is basically
allowing us and and producing the code
to facilitate okay the new refrigerants
so just as far as the efforts that have
happens
um so yes this uh hold on so
as far as the states that have failed in
Kentucky
Georgia Virginia Idaho why is that
failed is this just simply bad
bureaucrats at work
um well Kentucky quite honestly it was
very frustrating it was um I would say
more political
um than anything else I mean the
legislation was moving unanimously and
um we ended up they have a very short
session only a 30-day session we end up
getting hung up in the Senate on the
very last 11th Hour of the session and
unfortunately we couldn't couldn't get
it across in time and so now as a
fallback we're gonna have to work with
the Department to try to find some sort
of emergency provision or some sort of
administrative process in which we can
in which we can get this into effect and
I think everybody was pretty
disappointed in Kentucky with the
outcome I think the the the legislative
leadership as well as now the governor's
office having to now instead of having a
clean bill that could have just now
we've got to revert back to trying to
find something that fits into the hole
that we can get
stop Gap measure until they can get it
next session
but they're not overly concerned about
it
and it fails I mean they knew it was
going to fail what was their concern on
this I'm trying to get at what is the
issue is it simply people aren't meeting
deadlines it's just hard to believe
that's happening in that many states do
you know what I mean yeah no so a couple
of states are are unique right so
Virginia are we do we went through the
normal code process cycle our proposals
were adopted that's why it's in Orange
because we didn't pursue legislation
there in Georgia same thing we've had
our
um codes
um approved by their DCA Department of
Community Affairs and so that's why we
have that in Orange as well
um I appreciate it I don't want to go
through it I appreciate it I'm just I'm
just curious as to why people would be
opposed to this that's what I'm doing
but there's there's really it's not
there's no opposition there's no formal
opposition that I've encountered and
across all these states 27 States I've
been working in
um it's just a matter of
um again it's it's a mismatch in timing
that's all it is between the federal
phase down and the building code cycle
yeah it could well it could easily
happen here if we get bogged down in
working between the senate or here and
timing doesn't work out or something
happens and then it just doesn't get
done and then we're orange yeah on the
chart or red you don't want to go red
yeah
yeah I was just going to say Mr chair I
mean you know I'm from Pennsylvania
um I worked for our legislature for a
number of years we were able to get that
into the statute last year worked with
our building code officials they were
fine with it we really have not had much
any if all any pushback at all
um from building code officials once we
fully explain sort of again this
mismatch between the two and the
building code process again is so
unpredictable
um in many of these states some we've
submitted six proposals already and
they've all been rejected because well
we're not working on that right now
we're working on this and it's you know
we would be fine if this legislation
would pass clean and if uh obviously
that'd be our preferred route but if if
it would want to be tied with a sunset
to win the 2024 ICC model codes are
adopted uh we have no problem with that
we have actually done that in one or two
other states
um
uh in fact in Pennsylvania is what we we
actually did that as well
okay
um yes Mr Sherman come on back up
foreign
on my feet but I may have a solution
that fixes everybody's needs so ashrae
which is the American Society of heating
and Refrigeration if you want to munch a
little closer to the mic sorry
ashrae is another model code Group which
feeds into the Mechanical Code they have
two standards on refrigeration 15 and
34. both of those standards were updated
in the 2022 cycle I believe that they
probably address the issues that now
will be reflected in the 2024 Mechanical
Code one way to get out of this would be
to refer to ashrae
15-2022 and ashrae
34-2022 in the legislation and then sets
and the bill Sunset the bill when the
state codes catch up to it so we're not
referring back to state code we're
referring back to we've just given the
model code it's a clean version because
they're already published according to a
quick Google search
unfortunately these folks ought to look
at that and be sure that gets them what
they want and they can't do that during
the meeting here so well we don't have
to do anything today on this obviously
but um you know it's good to keep the
we've got a little bit of time to get it
through
so perhaps they could because we won't
be we won't be holding an exact session
for a couple weeks anyway so we've got
we've got a little bit of time
yeah I mean I certainly appreciate
suggestion and understand the um you
know the ashtray standards they have
been updated to reflect the safety
standards needed for these new
refrigerant classes refrigerants
um we in other states we've had the op
we've been proposed the opposite they
don't want to tie it to specific ashrae
standards especially if they're tied to
a particular year or version of the
ashrae standard because then that
becomes obsolete next time it's updated
you're already on a different version of
that bash rate standard I think well and
I think the point there though is it's
the temporary stop measure until the New
Hampshire code can get caught up back to
my initial point the concern is just
passing something with nothing in
reference nothing that we can go to
um and so then we're talking about
trying to slow down this particular Bill
until the building code can move forward
at the same time I think what he's
suggesting is that would be your stop
Gap we can attach that to the present
legislation get that through get that
done so you guys can start working and
then next year come back with the
building code to replace the asteroid
standards and then we just get rid of
the ashrae standards okay so Mr chair
just make sure I'm understanding so it
would be that this legislation will be
amended to Inc include references to the
ashrae standard and it also include a
sunset provision tied to the 2024 that's
that's the proposal that's building
codes being adopted yes I uh will have
you know I will have to um obviously
have people that I report to too but
that sounds logical to me
um I would just have to I can't make a
you know commitment right now at this
moment but I can get on the phone here
after the meeting and we'll be meeting
again before it goes back to the full
committee yeah on this so we have no
interest in amending State Building
Codes you know we don't want to be in in
the business of doing that
um this is just a unique situation that
we're trying to get out front of and
help help New Hampshire prepare for it
as well so right
any questions
oh
oh yeah Jeff
just
so for clarification there's
basically two proposals that I think
both sides could come to an agreement
that we may have to choose between using
the 2022 standards
or using
the amendment that was brought here
before us
um
I think would address either way the
issue provided that
the 22 2022 standards of ashrae have
what you're looking for for refrigerants
is that what um I think so yeah
yes sir I think that's actually um so
the point on the ashrae standards is
more towards the safety aspect so that
way there's you know if we if you were
to enact this in statute and
specifically reference the ashrae codes
there would at least be some interim
safety
um guidance until that was formalized in
the 2024 code process right so the
ashrae is more of standard referencing
Ash recent interview more for the safety
aspect
um and then the other language saying
basically that
um you can't prohibit an EPA approved
refrigerant in the state of New
Hampshire is is where that is at blanket
allowance that where that certainty that
we're looking for because we we can't
one one
thing we talked about out in the hallway
when I we just met out there was you
know local governments being more
restrictive than than the state you know
and that that just puts together a
regulatory framework in which we it's
hard to do business when there's some
refrigerants allowed in this
municipality or County summon this so we
want that blanket certainty that they're
approved in the state and if that means
tying it to a Sunset and an ashrae
safety standard as interim safety
guidance and I I would think that that
would work yeah I think I think the
overall goal is just to make sure that
you guys can continue to work right you
can continue to produce we can continue
to sell we can continue to do all that
stuff so as long as the solution
provides for that and you have
assurances that it's uh that's in place
I would assume that would meet your
concerns and then we just need to make
sure that we have a vehicle to get
um the code changes into the building
code
um
in the long term because that's where
ultimately won't we want the solution we
want the solution in code we don't want
it in statute so some vehicle out of the
ones that have been kind of battered
around today will have to come to an
agreement on which one we think is the
best vehicle for moving forward and
hopefully we can get the job done and
meet everybody's concerns at the same
time does that make sense
yes anything anything else from you or
um Papi take any questions but um we're
talking to anybody after the meeting
adjourns okay yeah I think
seems like everybody's good thank you
appreciate it okay thank you sir
any comments from the committee just as
a mode of discussion for what we've
talked about
concerns with any of the proposed ideas
or let's get some of this stuff down in
writing so that we've got something to
look at yeah
the building code review board is
meeting tomorrow so we'll have some
feedback what was there somebody else
who wanted to speak
come on up
for the record my name is Bob Clegg I
wrote the building code review board
statute when I was here I served as its
chair
and I would ask you not to tie that
temporarily to an ashrae or anything
else because there's no guarantee that
that ashrae standard is not going to
change and there's no guarantee that
we're going to adopt the building codes
of 2024 in fact we're having a problem
right now adopting or we're going to
have a problem adopting what they're
proposing
but the problem we do have that we need
to fix is the idea that something new is
coming along
and we can't use it on the outside
unless the legislature says we can we
can't wait two years
for the record I'm a developer I build a
lot of big buildings I build a lot of
Workforce housing and every time
somebody comes up with something new we
want to use it
but if I use it I know I take the the
responsibility if something goes wrong
especially since it hasn't been approved
by the building called review board
but if we keep styming everything what's
going to happen in the city in the state
is that we're going to have to buy the
old equipment we're going to have to pay
more for that refrigerant that's not
available
so I'm asking if you're going to do
anything pass it so we can use it
we know that when we buy that equipment
with that refrigerant and it's our
problem no matter what happens it's our
problem
but but if you want to do something
Sunset it in two years that allows you
to to re-up it
but not attached to any code that may
not be
reasonable enough for everybody in the
industry
to adopt
so it's important what you're doing here
I understand but it's also important
that it's not tied to anything else it's
a decision by the legislature building
code review board
used to have all the responsibility to
review them anyways
and I think that's more reasonable I'm a
developer like I said if I buy one of
those machines with that refrigerant in
it and something goes wrong it's my
problems
and and I think that's the way we should
we should approach it I'll tell you that
I was the first one to use 32 foot ply
lamps was what we called them in a day
for a roof and the code said I couldn't
because there was no code that said I
could
so it took me months
to find somebody who said we'll let you
use it but sign here if the roof
collapses
you're responsible I signed it and that
house is 28 years old today and there's
no problem
so if you let us in the industry figure
out what it is we need and what it is
we'll use
it'll make it a lot easier for those who
aren't in the industry to understand
I'll take any questions
and we don't want to wind up like in
Kentucky where they've hamstrung
themselves and they can't do anything
so let's get some of this stuff in
writing so we can look at it
yeah uh yeah and it doesn't seem like
anybody wants that to happen obviously I
think everybody seems like they want to
make sure that we can innovate and and
work with the latest stuff what was your
concern though about adopting the ashrae
standards temporarily if you would
the codes or what you do and that
standard changes
so does what you did so in all the years
I spent in the legislature we tried not
to use something by reference if there's
something in the ashrae code you want to
use put it in
but don't say Ashley 15 because if
tomorrow somebody makes a change to it
now we're Bound by that because the
legislature said just that number
we
thank you chair
couldn't you simply not that I'm in fan
I really don't have a position on any of
this stuff I think it's just you know
less government better but couldn't you
just cite that particular code though
they have different editions like when
we get Amendments of zero zero zero one
eight can you just say this ashrae at
this point because you can't have a
floating you you could try to say in
effect as of this date yeah but you
would have to call and make sure the day
you adopt it it didn't change in the
meantime I mean we
all right it is an ongoing yeah I
understand what you're saying yeah all
right thank you
any any other questions
thank you so much for testifying
appreciate that for your input Mr
Sherman did you have something you want
to attend no we're good
all right um I'm gonna close up the work
session for this time then
um we can
continue the conversation we'll get some
stuff done on writing so that we can
consider some different options and then
um we'll call another meeting and
hopefully finish this up and be able to
push something too exact does that make
sense yeah
representative true
the old guy
I sort of like the the discussion that
you don't even need this
um
so um so well we won't we won't need it
once it's in code
so right yeah
and that they're working on they're
working the building then biomass
they're working on the codes so they
will meet it
whether we pass this or not that's
that's their job
the question is when it becomes
effective
so
um how long will it take to get the code
produced passed can we be assured that
they will pass and those are the
questions that are kind of up in the air
so if if for some reason the code
doesn't pass
and we don't pass something like this
then they just can't we can't buy those
refrigerants
thank you
who else
all right I'm closing up the work
session then thank you